"
>> GOOD EVENING, EVERYONE, I AM
LAURA INGRAM AND THIS IS "THE
INGRAM ANGLE."
PETE BUTTIGIEG HAS WENT TO THE
TOP OF THE WISH LIST AND WE WILL
EXPLAIN MY COMING UP NEXT.
BUT FIRST, THE FOCUS OF
TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
AND IT TURNS OUT THEN MICKEY
MOUSE HAS MORE FRIENDS THAN HIS
FRIENDS.
HIS NAME IS TIM COOK.
EMPLOYING THE SAME TACTICS BY
MISCHARACTERIZING THE LAWS THAT
THEY SPENT MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
LOBBYING AGAINST, WHEN IN
REALITY THEY WERE AIMED AT
PROTECTING CHILDREN AND WOMEN.
BEHIND THE SCENES APPLE IS ONE
OF THE MOST CORPORATE ADVOCATES
AND THE COMPANY HAS TRIED TO
LEVERAGE ITS GREATEST ASSETS.
THE POPULARITY OF PRODUCTS BASED
IN THE UNITED STATES CRUSH THE
LEGISLATION.
FLORIDA'S PARENTAL RIGHTS
EDUCATION BILL ARE PRO-CHILD AND
AIMED AT PROTECTING LITTLE ONES
PURITY K THROUGH THIRD GRADE.
WE DON'T CALL LAWS BANNING KIDS
ANTI-AUTOMOBILE.
AND LAWS THAT PREVENT BIOLOGICAL
MALES FROM COMPETING AGAINST
WOMEN.
THEY PROTECT GIRLS AND WOMEN WHO
HAVE OFTEN WORKED THEIR ENTIRE
LIVES TO EXCEL AT THE HIGHEST
LEVELS OF ATHLETICS.
ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY KNOW ALL
THAT, THEY ARE NOT STUPID.
WHICH IS WHY THEY HAVE TO LIE
ABOUT THE LOSS.
THEIR POSITION THAT IT'S OKAY
FOR SCHOOLS TO TUTOR CHILDREN
AND THE COMPLEXITIES OF SEXUAL
AND GENDER IDENTITIES IS
INDISPENSABLE AND WILL NOT STOP
CALLING THEM OUT ON IT EVER.
OR STOP EXPOSING THIS TO ROB OUR
CHILDREN AND SUBVERT THE CORE
RIGHTS TO RAISE THEIR CHILDREN
WITH THEIR OWN CULTURAL AND
RELIGIOUS VALUES.
AND THAT INCLUDES INTERNAL
DISNEY VIDEOS THAT WE TALKED
ABOUT, ABOUT HOW RADICAL OF A
COMPANY THEY HAD BECOME.
THEY ARE OBVIOUSLY WORRIED.
MICHELLE GOLDBERG SAW HOW
EFFECTIVE OUR COVERAGE WAS AND
IT GAVE HER A CASE OF THE
VAPORS.
ESPECIALLY WITH THE USE OF
GROOMING THAT WE USE IN REGARDS
TO ADULTS IN THE CLASSROOM WHO
ARE INSISTENT ABOUT DISCUSSING
INTIMATE TOPICS WITH
5-YEAR-OLDS.
INCLUDING EXPOSING YOUNG KIDS TO
EXPLICIT MATERIALS PRIMING THEM
FOR ABUSE HAS GONE MAINSTREAM.
FIRST OF ALL, "THE NEW YORK
TIMES," THEY ARE COMPLETE FRAUDS
WHEN IT COMES TO THE ISSUES THAT
THEY SO MUCH CARE ABOUT.
BUT IF YOU ASKED THE EXECUTIVE
EDITOR OF THE TIMES WHICH IS THE
BIGGER THREAT TO AMERICANS, IS
IT TRUMP SUPPORTERS?
AND AS FOR APPLE, THEY ARE TIED
UP FINANCIALLY BIG TIME WITH THE
PCP WHICH HAS ZERO RIGHTS OR ANY
ETHNIC RIGHTS.
THEY PUBLISHED A STUNNING REPORT
REVEALING THAT TIM COOK HIMSELF
MADE A SECRET DEAL BACK IN 2016
THAT WAS WORTH MORE THAN
$275 BILLION.
THIS FIVE-YEAR AGREEMENT WAS
MADE OVER THE COURSE OF SEVERAL
IN-PERSON MEETINGS IN CHINA.
HE WAS TRYING TO SALVAGE THE
RELATIONSHIP WITH CHINESE
OFFICIALS AND THEY THOUGHT THE
COUNTRY WAS NOT CONTRIBUTING
ENOUGH TO THE CHINESE ECONOMY.
AND THAT INCLUDES A FIRST
CHINESE SUPPLIER.
WHERE'S YOUR ADVOCACY, OR WAS IT
AGAINST THE PCP BULLDOZING
CHURCHES AND TERRORIZING
RELIGIOUS ORDERS.
>> A LEADERSHIP POSITION FOR THE
WORLD, IN MANY DIFFERENT AREAS.
THEY HAVE EXTRAORDINARY SKILLS.
THE NUMBER ONE ATTRACTION IS THE
QUALITY OF PEOPLE.
SO WE HAVE AN EXTRAORDINARY
RELATIONSHIP FOR OVER THREE
DECADES, REALLY.
>> SILENCE ABOUT THEIR OVERLORD,
BUT VOCAL OPPOSITION IN THE
UNITED STATES.
THINK ABOUT THAT FOR A MOMENT.
IT GOT REALLY RAMPED UP, AS YOU
WILL RECALL DURING THE GEORGE
FLOYD CHAOS.
MEANWHILE SMALL BUSINESSES ALL
ACROSS AMERICA WERE BEING
TORCHED.
WE MET COMPANIES LIKE THIS MUST
BECOME AN ALLY TO THE MOVEMENT.
>> YOU HAVE TO START TRYING TO
DO MORE TO END UP BRINGING ABOUT
SOCIAL CHANGE.
>> IT IS NOT A NEW TOPIC.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT COMES
FROM THE VALUES OF OUR BUSINESS.
>> YES, THE MUCH WANTED VALUES
THAT THEY HOLD SUCH AS WRITING,
LOOTING, CAPITALISM AND THE
NUCLEAR FAMILY THAT SHOULD BE
ABOLISHED.
AND AS FOR THE VALUE OF VOTER
INTEGRITY ENSURING THAT ITS CAST
BY ELIGIBLE VOTERS.
>> TRYING TO RESTRICT THE VOTERS
ACCESS TO THE POLLS, IT IS
DISPROPORTIONATELY HURTING BLACK
AND BROWN COMMUNITIES.
>> THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS
MORE THAN MONEY.
THIS IS ABOUT PROTECTING THE
VOICES OF OUR PEOPLE.
>> IT IS ABOUT NONE OF THAT.
AND THAT WAS ABOUT ONE SET OF
POLITICAL ACTIVISTS AT THE
EXPENSE OF COMMON SENSE AND FAIR
PLAY.
THESE BUSINESSES SHOULD REALLY
LEARN THIS LESSON NOW BEFORE
IT'S TOO LATE, STAY IN YOUR
LANE.
BECAUSE IF THEY WANT TO TALK
ABOUT WHAT THEY KNOW NOTHING
ABOUT, EXPECT TO BE TREATED LIKE
ANY POLITICAL PUNDIT.
EXCEPT IN YOUR CASES.
YOU GUYS HAVE PRODUCTS AND
SERVICES, THAT THEY DON'T NEED
TO PURCHASE IF THEY DON'T WANT
TO.
AND WHEN THEY GET BACK INTO
POWER, APPLE AND DISNEY NEED TO
UNDERSTAND ONE THING.
EVERYTHING WILL BE ON THE TABLE,
YOUR COPYRIGHT, TRADEMARK
PROTECTION, SPECIAL STATUS AND
EVEN CORPORATE STRUCTURE ITSELF.
MANY NEED TO BEGIN THE PROCESS
OF CONSIDERING WHICH AMERICAN
COMPANIES NEED TO BE BROKEN UP
ONCE AND F